شيرين عبد الوهاب اللي ما غاب اسمها عن
الاخبار وبتصدرت العناوين منذ شهور ما
زالتضمن العناوين الرئيسيه واسمها تريند
على المنصه من امس وذلك بسبب مفاجاه غير
متوقعه فجرتها شيرين فمسلسل شيرين وحسام
حبيب تعددت حلقاته وتنوعت عناوين تلك
الحلقات من الحب والزواج للالتهامات
والطلاق وانتهاء ايضا بالمخدرات والامراض
النفسيه
والمستشفيات هذا طبعا غير الشائعات
الكثيره الفنانه شيرين اللي عانت خلال
الفتره الماضيه من ظروف صحيه او عفوا ظروف
شخصيه وحتى صحيه ايضا صعبه ظهرت للعلم
ودخلت على اثرها المستشفى للعلاج لفتره
قبل خروجها من ايام وكانت المفاجاه امس
باعلانها للناس عبره برنامج الحكايه مع
الاعلامي عمرو القديم
شيرين انت عندك خبر سعيد عايزه تقولي لي
الناس وانا حابب ان الخبر ده يتقال عندنا
هنا في البرنامج عشان نفرح معك كل اللي
الناس ايه الخبر السعيد اللي عندك
النهارده
[موسيقى]
بمشيئه رب العالمين كتب كتابي على السيد
حسام
الف مبروك الله يبارك فيك
والنبي صلى الله عليه وعلى اله وصحبه من
قال اذا جاءكم من ترضون خلقه ودينه فزوجوه
فتنه في الارض وفساد كبير
وان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
فيها كتاب الله عز وجل وان يهجر فيها
الذكر الحكيم بقول الله عز وجل ومن يعشوا
عن ذكر الرحمن الشيطان فهو له
وقال النبي الامين صلى الله عليه وسلم
مثل البنت الذي ذكر فيه الماء والبيت الذي
لا يذكر الحي والميت ودائما يعني نحسن
انفسنا بافكار كان يقول النبي صلى الله
عليه وسلم في كل صباح زي مثلا لا اله الا
الله
التامه من كل شيطان ومن كل عين لما وقبل
النبي عليه الصلاه والسلام اعوذ بكلمات
الله التامات من شر ما خلق فهذا يعني امان
للبيوت ونسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يجمع
بينكما في الخير
يعني مثل ما سمعتوا وشاهدته مشاهدينا
الفنانه شيرين بنفسها اعلنت عودتها لزوجها
حسام حبيب وبهذا الاعلان تنتهي بكل
الشائعات اللي لاحقه الثنائي خلال الفتره
الماضيه شيرين اكدت خلال المكالمه
الهاتفيه في برنامج الحكايه على انها
تتمتع بصحه جيده الان وامورها الصحيه في
تحسن واضافت ايضا انها سامحت اخوها محمد
اللي كان السبب في ادخالها المستشفى
للعلاج وتم تداول ايضا معلومات انه ضربها
ووجهت رساله لمحبيها ولا حسام حبيب كمان
هتنازل عن اي حاجه انا كنت عاملها
لمحمد سعيد عبد الوهاب
بينك وبين اخوك خلاص هتشيليها طبعا لان
انا ما اقدرش اعمل كده انا انا انا شيرين
اللي قلبها متسامح وهيفضل متسامح بعتذر
لحسام عن كلام قدر مني في يوم من الايام
فانا عايزه اطمنهم علي واقول لهم ان هنا
في عصره راجل طيب جدا
وحبيب من البدايه ولو كنت طلعت في يوم من
الايام قلت كلام عنه همم كان هو ما زعلني
منه او كلام بيده الشيطان بيحصل بين اي
اثنين متجوزين واحنا كان معمول لنا حاجه
كبيره قوي قوي
واحنا كنا ضحيه حاجه كبيره قوي قوي والحمد
لله ربنا فكها بسلام
عموما من بدايه قصه شيرين وحسام كثير من
الناس متابعين التطورات ومتعطين بشكل او
باخر مع شريف من بينهم طبعا فنانين اظهروا
ادعمهم لشيرين خلال وجودها في المستشفى
لكن اللي صار انه من بعد ما اعلنت 20 خبر
عودتها لحسام اتفضل هاشتاج اين الكرامه يا
شيرين تصدر المنصات وجمهورها وعدد من
الفنانين يعتبروا عودتها هو النوع من
التعلق واهدار للكرامه وخاصه انه 20 سابقا
كانت قالت انها بحاجه الى معجزه للعوده لا
حسام حبيب
سنعود مره اخرى للقاهره والناقد الفني
طارق الشناوي هناك اهلا فيك استاذ طارق هل
تسمعني الان
تمام
تتحدث عنها الفنانه شيرين بانها لن تعود
الى او محتاجه لمعجزه لحتى تعود لحسام
حبيب المعجزه بالفعل تحققت وعادت الان
باعتقد بانه كثير من متابعين ومحبين
الفنانه شيرين بطلوا فاهمين اي حاجه
ايه اللي بيحصل
لا انا انا انا انا فاهم طبعا هي في حاله
نفسيه واضح يعني مش هتحتاج تكون طبيب نفسي
او متخصص في الطب النفسي انك انت تعرف انت
امام شخصيه زجزاجيه
ثنائيه القطب يعني يعني دائما تتنقل من
اقصى اليمين لاقصى اليسار من اقصر رفض
لاقصى الموافقه من من اسوا الالفاظ
والصفات اللي بتلعب بها طليقها الى اعظم
الصفات والاقوال
طارق
هذا اللي عم بتقوله اه
اه هي شخصيه فعلا
ثنائيه القطب يعني رايحه جايه يعني حابه
فوق وحبه تحت مش مش وبعدين هي كانت في
المستشفى لمده 20 يوم ومستشفى المفروض
انها علاج نفسي وطلعت لما انسان بيطلع
اولا كنا مكنه المده دي كلها معناه ان كان
في مشكله مش ان حد عمل فيها يعني همم
مؤامره واتخالها لا معناها ان في مشكله ان
اطباء همم قالوا تقعد المده دي كلها
وخروجها لا يعني نهايه همم التعافي لا
ممكن بدايه التعافي لكن لا يعني التعافي
المطلق
وعشان كده القرارات اللي بتتخذها برده
قرارات متطرفه يعني ازاي لسه خارجه بقى من
يومين وبعد كده بعد ساعات يعقد قرارنا على
من اتهمته على الملا امام الراي العام كله
بصفات صعب ان الواحد يعيدها مره اخرى على
امراه من الجمهور في حاجه مش طبيعيه على
باطل فهو باطل يعني يعني قرار الزواج نفسه
مبني على شخصيه غير قادره على اتخاذ قرار
صائب في اللحظه دي طيب وغير مستعد على
الاطلاق
الشخصيه وهي حره تتزوج او همم تطلق من
تريد يعني وتعود لمن تريد بس هي الفكره
لما يكون في فنان
ما هذا هذا اللي انا جاي له في الحديث
احنا كم محبين لا او جمهور الفنانه شيرين
هو نوعا ما طرف في الموضوع على الاقل او
طرف همم يعني همم
همم استثمر عاطفيا بهذه القصه من واقع حبه
للفنانه شيرين لما بيكون فيه لغط بحياه
همم فنان الشخصيه لهذه الدرجه وهذا اللغط
يكون على الملا وعلى العالم وعلى السوشيال
ميديا كيف بياثر على جماهيرته وحب الناس
لا له ثقتهم في ايضا
طبعا هي وراثه الناس في معركه خاصه زي ما
حضرتك قلتي دي حاله خاصه جدا بتحصل بين
ازواج طلاق وحب وزواج وخيانه وغيرها
وغيرها عادي دي الحياه هكذا هي الحياه لكن
هي صدرت كل ده من الراي العام فبالتالي
الراي العام ايضا ان يكون لها وجهه نظر
سلبيه في الشخصيه طبعا هناك صوره ذهنيه
سلبيه متعلقه بشرين في هذه اللحظه ههه
بيقول اين الكرامه يا شيرين هذا همم جدي
يعني ههه
والله انا حياتي الشخصيه وانا حره فيها
شخصيه اصبحت حياه مباحه للراي العام كله
ومباحه من خلالها في فرق بين ثلاث سوس احد
بيكتب اخبار عن شيرين وفي فرق بين ان هي
اللي بتذيع هذه الاخبار بكل هذا الوضوح
وكل هذا العنف والتطرف في الناحيتين سواء
في الهجوم او في الدفاع وبعدين تدخل بقى
فكره المعمول لهم عمل وحاجات كده يعني
داخله داخله في قضيه كمان يعني لا يجوز
حتى انه في في الزمن ده حد يتكلم عن سحر
وسحره نعم نعم حاجه يعني يعني الامور كلها
ملخبطه وليست في صالح شيرين برغم انها
واحده من اهم الاصوات على الساحه العربيه
قطعه يعني نتمنى لها كل الخير طبعا
الفنانه المحبوبه شيرين وشكرا جزيلا لك
الناقد الفني طارق الشناوي كان معنا
القاهره
[موسيقى]